i cannot imagine that computers will be
in people's houses anytime soon but they
might be at the local pharmacy okay
right and they and if you've got a drug
manufacturing facility in every town
then you just go and they give you a
prescription they do it in such a way
they format it so that you you don't
have to take 10 pills every day you get
one manufactured for you that has all
the materials you need and the right
distribution got it but you mentioned
recreational drugs and and the reason i
mentioned because i know people are
going to
speak up on this if the drug is legal
there's to me no reason why you can't
manufacture
i mean for recreation i mean you can do
it what do you have against
fondly i
i haven't so i mean i'm a chemistry
professor in a university who is an
entrepreneur as well i just think i need
to be as responsible as i can in the
discussion sure um not sure but i know
i'm so let me be the one that says like
there's nothing because you have said
recreational drugs and like terrorism in
the same sentence yeah yeah i think okay
i think let's make sure we draw a line
uh that there's
real dangers to the world of terrorists
of bio warfare and then there's a little
bit of weed
so
i have i mean i i think it's up to the
society to yes to tell is governments
what it wants what's acceptable right
and if it becomes let's say that thcs
become
you know heavily
acceptable and that you can modify them
so let's say there's let's say it's like
blood type there's a particular type of
thc that you that you tolerate better
than i do
then why not why not have a machine that
makes the one you like yeah and then and
why not the perfect brownie okay and i i
think that that's fine um
but i'm you know i we're so far away
from that i can barely get the thing to
work in the lab right i mean it's
reliability and all this other stuff but
what i think is going to happen in the
short term it's going to turbo charge
molecular discovery reliability and that
will change the world that's super
exciting
you